well we might actually kick things up as
the last couple of people roll into the
room hi I'm Scott Holden and I'm gonna
do the obligatory boring intro slide in
a second and this is kubernetes zero to
we're really looking at a you've had
some previous experience with containers
you may have played around with them a
little we're gonna revisit a little bit
of that knowledge as well just to make
sure what a ground level set I'm gonna
take it from there we're going to assume
little to no knowledge about kubernetes
itself and more importantly we're going
to assume why we don't know why we
actually need Hooven it is as well so
it's important to actually make the
distinction between container runtimes
and kubernetes and all that we will
drill into that in a lot more detail but
to begin ioan most boring intro slide
you'll see this entire week I'm Scott
Holden you can reach me via email or
github that's pretty much it I work for
Microsoft so obligatory opinions are
that of my own not of that my employer I
work as an advanced migration technical
specialist which is slightly different
to kubernetes become from a very active
heavy background so to kick things off I
thought let's start with a bit of a
level set by running through containers
themselves now you can ask some fun
questions how many people have used
containers technology in any way shape
or form before awesome how many people
have used kubernetes devs prod or
whatever is cool got a couple of hats
hopefully there'll be a couple of things
for you today and I'm guessing the rest
of you have an interest in kubernetes
but either haven't found the right
trigger moment the right reason to
actually begin using it or to be
perfectly honest if things work why
would I even consider kubernetes so
we'll run through that as well so our
visiting containers we are not talking
about Bailey's if you are here to
discuss the scheduling and orchestration
of Tupperware you are in the wrong order
we instead we'll be talking about a
container as a logical unit and we're
going to run through a little bit of
terminology at the moment there seems to
be a real disconnect in terms of what we
call containers people will call
containers container images
oh sorry people call container images
containers people will call container
run
containers at its core what a container
is is your code in a runtime or put even
more simply a single process that's
running isolated from the world around
us and it may in turn have a series of
drivers providing process namespace
process isolation file system isolation
resource isolation in terms of maximum
CPU and memory and its own network stack
or network isolation so when we talk
about a container for the rest of the
day we're really going to be talking
about this construct a piece of code a
program running inside what we could
nearly term as a sandbox now as soon as
you see this we think we'll hang on a
second we've had this for years in
virtual machines virtual machines
provide a way to extract our hardware
and network our compute resources and as
with any good container presentation we
have to have the obligatory VMs verse
containers what is the difference well
in a virtual machine we carry around the
operating system which is quite heavy so
it means all these virtual machines are
carrying around every single component
when we look at I'm gonna pick on a
Windows install it's not the lightest
thing in the world
so having five ten fifteen hundred
copies of it can be quite expensive in
terms of storage where a container
differs is that we share the kernel with
the base underlying operating system so
there are some shared components there
in turn we get the benefit of not
actually carrying around the operating
system so all of a sudden we have our
app in our runtime the only components
that are required to run the container
as part as part of our package as part
of our container image we need a little
bit deeper into that now there's one
issue I have with this image and every
single image like that it is everyone
tries to make the blue boxes the same
does anyone have an application in
runtime that are half the size of their
operating system that would be like
three or four key in reality your app
and runtime a small little components
compared to your operating system and
this is where one of the benefits of
containers actually comes into play that
you can fit a lot more density
on a server in terms of actually running
these workloads so this is what I think
the diagram should actually look like
because we can fit a lot more we can
better utilize the capacity we have
using containers because we're not
repeating that operating system
component so how do we actually go from
a container image to something running
well we'll begin to container images in
a second but in order to spin up a
container we need to provide a container
image a file system and a little bit of
lightweight configuration and it really
depends on how deep into this you want
to go this is the important part we pass
the configuration and the container
image to a container runtime that
container run timer is then responsible
for actually spinning everything up
behind the scenes in turn you get a
running container now running container
is not a single component it's a whole
lot of different services in the
background that are actually working
together to provide all these different
levels of isolation and abstraction now
you'll notice so far I haven't said the
D word and it's what's really
popularized containers the technology
that's actually underpinning all of this
has been around for ages the C name our
C groups have been around further I
don't even want to think how long
process namespaces and process
isolations even longer so the technology
isn't new what is new and fancy though
is these awesome toolkits that actually
provide all of these components in one
place so docker became really popular
and that was the D word I was talking
about it this is a PG docker really
provides a toolkit to actually allow you
to put all this together it provides the
tools to create those container images
those file systems it then provides the
container runtime for you to actually
pass the image into to get those
services behind the scenes spun up and
it also provides then the long-term
management being able to stop monitor
get loss you can perform everything
docker can do using individual
components and individual services and
if you have a bit of free time read up
on
see and what was actually doing under
the hood there's a whole lot of really
cool stuff happening but what docker
gives us is the ability to do docker run
now for the majority of this talk when
we refer to Dhaka we're gonna be
referring it in in the use case of the
container runtime something we pass a
container image to to have it to execute
the container itself so now further ado
let's run an a simple container
hopefully this will seem fairly familiar
to everyone so here I've got a virtual
machine rather than running on my local
laptop just give me a little bit more
rapid and to please the demo gods on
this I've got installed docker desktop
now docker desktop is a way of actually
running the local doctor Damon on my
local computer now because I actually
want to deal with Linux containers today
it's actually spun off a virtual machine
in the background that's doing all the
heavy lifting for me so I'm actually a
couple layers deep in terms of
virtualization and dr. desktop is
fantastic to run on your local computer
this is really about a local doctor
experience now the reason I really
wanted to call this out is I'm running
Windows yet I'm working with Linux
containers I can flip this around to use
windows containers as well but we're
gonna stick in the world of Linux for
the moment so I'm gonna come into my
command prompt and in order to interact
with docker and we'll we won't dig too
deep into dr. today I'm gonna do a
docker and let's just do - - help - -
helps really helpful because it gives
you all the information of everything
you can do in order to start a container
and once again hopefully this is seeming
fairly familiar to a few people we do
docker run on and then we need to pass
our container image plus a series of
options into docket run remember we have
that plus configuration down the bottom
so I'm gonna pass in - D which means run
in a detached mode so in this example we
want to actually have it running in the
back
round rather than having it stay open
and wait for us to close it off I'm
gonna be really really clean here and do
- - erm if you're working with docker
this will become your friend
this literally means when the container
stops running clean up everything that
way you don't end up with a whole lot of
stopped containers sitting around so
particular for today now I'm actually
going to be running a web server here to
demonstrate what we're doing has
everyone heard of it in genetics fairly
popular you put in place here is Apache
HTTP D any any web service you want but
I'm gonna pick on Emily next cuz the
containers quite nice so we're gonna run
run nginx and I need to add one more
option to actually get this to work if I
was to execute this right now it will
spin up isolating the process space
isolated filesystem doesn't really set
any limits on computer memory
utilization
it'll also set up its own little
networking stack and unless I actually
tell docker I would like to interact
with that a network I won't have access
into this container so I'm going to add
one more command - P 80 80 80 and this
is I would like to map port 8080 on my
computer into port 80 running on the
container now this is the quintessential
first docker workload that everybody
runs so and there are many examples of
how to do this if we actually kick this
off the first thing we notice we get
this big massive show on hash this is
our containers identity running inside
dr. this is our running a container to a
degree if we do a docker PS we can
actually see what's running in the
background and you can ignore a couple
of those demo faults they weren't meant
to show up just yet it's just at the top
so we're running engine X and we said it
should be available on port 8080 so if
we were to open up our browser go to hey
got nginx running inside a container
that that's it that's running a
container on daughter now it will stay
there running until we explicitly tell
it to stop so I'm just going to do a
docker stop now protip
containers get names and they're awesome
fun names things like whatever it is you
don't need to type them in a really
short hand way of actually addressing
anything within docker is to just use
the first couple of characters to
uniquely identify the hash so in this
case I can see my top-level engine X
container has a container ID starting
with a nine a and that's actually unique
so I should be able to type stop a 980
and that will stop that container that I
was looking at you so really shorthand
it means you don't have to write things
out now if we would have come back to
our browser refresh this it all timeout
and say hey it's off it's not available
we'll shut down the container okay
alright let's jump back and dig a little
bit further so what is a container image
and once again this might be running
over some known ground for most people
what a container image is drastically
different to what we think of when we
look at virtual machine hard drives or
even a physical hard drive a container
image is actually made up of a whole lot
of layers and like onions and parfait
layers is good the container image
itself is based on top of a previous
image that in turn is based on a
previous image that is in turn based on
scratch scratch is the very bottom point
when we talk about scratch it means
nothing on the file system think of it
like a blank harddrive if we actually
take a look at what we were running
there say for example nginx looking at
the second one down nginx in this case
is based on the Debian Buster slim image
which that is based on scratch now one
of the key things to note here is we
only bring along each layer as is needed
and we only store the deltas and this is
it seems a little bit silly at first but
it's absolutely amazing because it means
if we just need Debian we've got 69
megawatts of utilization if we then need
nginx we add on additional 56 minute if
we then need some custom code
top of that and we'll talk about how
some container images in a second 1k
whatever it may be the other benefit we
get is if multiple containers use the
same layer below its share between the
two in terms of being downloaded once
stored once but being able to be
referenced so all of a sudden for all
these base layers we only need to keep
one with copy of them we can also do
this this is really fun come chat to me
later if you want to talk about running
images on scratch and doing really fun
things with net cool this is a little
bit of a beat but anyway let's have a
quick look at making a container image
because this is something that I find a
lot of people skip over and we're gonna
do it a slightly different way and ask a
trick question here how many people
think you need a doctor file to contain
to create a container image couple
people Coco said it was a trick question
and you actually don't need a docker
file at all so what I'm about to show
you is absolutely disgusting you
probably shouldn't do it in production
but it's a great way to actually
understand how a container image is made
up so I actually want to change my nginx
page so it shows something completely
different so I'm gonna rerun my index
container so it's sitting up and running
and if we come back to our browser we
should see that we've got welcome to
nginx I don't like this I wanted to say
hello world that's that's the classic
example so from the command line line
I'm actually gonna enter into the
container I'm gonna connect to its
process namespace and spawn my own
process side by side to a degree this
allows me to run whatever I want inside
the container itself so if I do in a
docker exe C I'm gonna do - I T because
I want this to be interactive so I can
talk with it and to be TTY so terminal
experience on this I'm gonna run with
the container that I just spun up which
starts with 9 - EE and I'm gonna run a
command in this case I'm gonna run one
batch what this is actually done is
started the batch process inside the
container sitting completely isolated
now because I'm now inside the container
inside of process name space with its
attached file system and networking I
can begin to interact with all of those
components say for example I wanted to
create a new web page well I could do an
echo hello world for example and right
about to use a nginx
index dot HTML don't worry too much
about that half this is more showing
that we can change the file system of
the container on the fly so if we
actually come back to index now and
refresh we get out hello world dot
commitment now the reason we reason the
general guidance is never to do this on
a container is if we would have stopped
it we lose all of these changes changes
to a file system are completely
temporary the images themselves are
mutable but we can take the changes with
Maggie and convert them into a container
image and this is this is the part that
necessarily wouldn't recommend it but
it's great to have an understanding off
so if we come back into the command
prompt we can actually do a commit so we
want to fix it out and the whole idea
behind commit is we want to take changes
we've made to a running container and
pull it with the filesystem back into an
image so I'm gonna do a docker committed
and I'm gonna pass in my container in
this case what's calling 9/2 and we can
give it a repository and tag so I might
just call this live one latest so we
give me the name and a tag I hit this
cool we've just created a container
image we've created another layout so if
I was to do a docker stop ix we we take
our webserver down if I was to now run
the exact same command as before but
instead of specifying nginx I specify
live 1 latest we actually kick out web
server back up with all the file system
changes that were made so we jump over
here we refresh
nothing actually changes which created a
copy of our of our file system now why
is this important to know well when you
see a docker file something like this
what does random run is the equivalent
of jumping into the container executing
that command and then taking a snapshot
of the resulting file system so when you
have run commands in a docker container
docker file it's the same as actually
jumping in making those changes and then
taking a snapshot this is important to
remember for one week reason and we'll
get into versions a little bit later on
if you've got a component that's not
identified every time you call it it
gives you a different result every time
you build this docker container you're
going to get a completely different
result and the big one that often
catches out people is things like apt
install or get installed if you're just
doing a generic apt-get install and not
specifying a version every time we
rebuild the container you just grab the
latest version of the software which may
be the behavior you want but it may also
be a little bit dangerous so the other
way to build a container as we all know
use the docker file and do a docker
build and you won't want me to run over
that quickly or let's get on to the fun
stuff sorry
yes so the equivalent from at the top
here was the same as starting the old
image so from nginx here was the same as
the run nginx we then ran this command
the biggest difference is this does it
all automatically for us there's a lot
easier to read
whereas we said from nginx makes Ansari
start nginx make some changes save a
copy of that file system which actually
keeps all of those layers in place so
there's actually a reference back to
nginx inside of that container image
itself cool let's jump over in do
securities
the last thing I'll just mention before
we jump over is we've got container
images where do we put them at the point
of building and they stay on our local
machine and in fact for things like
nginx and Alpine or Debian depending on
what bearing you have they're stored in
docker hub and these are shorthand names
for containers stored in different
registries so we can pull those
container images down we can also push
push any custom containers up to our own
private container registry so we can
access them privately now something like
Internet's it's designed to be public so
it makes sense to be in a public
registry for a private container with
our own code I mean we may want it in a
private container registry examples of
this could be like as a container
registry or you can even run your own
from scratch if you want to we're not
going to dig any further into this but
just keep in mind this is the way we
actually distribute our container images
so if we see any image references
container image references from this
point forward we're either pulling it
from the docker hub directly if it's a
public image or we're pulling it from
our private container registry if it
starts with a particular name
okay so what's the challenge with all
this containers look really cool and you
can run them in production you can grab
docker productionize it by itself just
just the container runtime and nothing
else war one container one host not too
bad
like you can manage it and a lot of
people will actually treat a single
container like a Windows service a few
containers across a few hosts gets a
little bit trickier how do you begin to
manage and look after all these things
as soon as you have lots of containers
across many hosts so it's really a
full-time job just stuff just writing
docker run on docker stoppable trust me
there are people out there that focus
fueling under starting and stopping
starting and stopping containers but
there's a lot more than is actually one
who's failures what happens do we move
the container there's nothing in a
container runtime that's even hosts
aware we have to move it ourselves so
that means logging into another server
spinning it up what happens if that
server comes back online which one do we
take off which pod do we take offline
how do we turn things on and off how do
we do service discovery how do we know
where these containers actually live how
do we know which ones to talk to is this
container healthy how do we know if
something's healthy or not how to
restart it how many copies of things do
we run if we want to scale in and out
does that mean spinning up a new server
installing the dr. runtime container
runtime on it and starting the container
deploying new versions how do we do
updates do we spin them up side by side
what's our policy required configuration
do we go through and check every single
host so that all the right containers
are running it if any of these scenarios
sound familiar it's actually a perfect
use case for kubernetes now you make it
into the very first box that blew up
which is one container one host a very
simple scenario in kubernetes maybe a
little bit of overkill for that but for
any other scenarios especially any
listed here it's really designed to make
it a little bit easier so introducing
kubernetes
what is kubernetes or more importantly
what are the headline component
that make people gravitate towards
kubernetes well the first one is
scheduling actually setting up
containers across multiple different
hosts affinity anti affinity deciding
where to actually put these containers
health monitoring and failover deciding
how to run those workloads in a reliable
way
scaling being able to scale on scale
containers in and out networking service
discovery coordinated upgrades but if
there's one thing I want you to take
away today and this is probably the most
basic thing in terms of running
workloads kubernetes is a scheduler
kubernetes doesn't actually run your
containers and this is something that
most people will go hang on a second
that doesn't sound right no I'm using
kubernetes to run my containers
no no kubernetes talks to a container
runtime that container runtime runs your
containers kubernetes is just simply the
scheduler that sits on top that
orchestrates those container runtimes to
do their thing and the reason I offer a
reason I'm constantly same container
runtime docker while it is the default
option here's one of many options that
are currently available you can use to a
degree any container runtime under
kubernetes with its pluggable
architecture so big thing to take away
kubernetes is a scheduler you still need
to contain a runtime on the mix to
actually run your containers we know
it's a scheduler we know confused for a
whole lot of things but what is cuvee
ninis I mean if we have to have a
physical thing that was kubernetes what
is it well it's made up of masters and
work on notes so our master notes which
you may or may not be familiar with
depending if you've started with a cloud
offering or not is what actually runs
kubernetes this is our control plane
this is where the brains behind
kubernetes actually runs this talks with
individual worker nodes which we'll
cover in a second to execute workloads
on those container runtimes and it's
normally a cluster you normally have a
set of master nodes because you want it
to be highly available a common
configuration might be three master
nodes
five worker nodes now when are each our
first
one hundred-plus slide we're going 0 to
100 today but if you want to go above a
hundred and remember a little bit more
we can actually look at the rolls inside
of cou bonitas itself and Joshua is
doing a session a little bit later on
today going into a lot of depth around
this I believe yeah so if you want to
know more about this attending Joshua's
given any session a little bit later on
but at a call the master contains three
key components with regards to
kubernetes the API server this is what
we talk to to actually create create and
set up our configurations the cube
scheduler which decides hey which node
should these workloads actually sit on
and the cube controller manager which
actually takes control of all the all
the other components inside the
ecosystem and I'm being fairly abstract
here because we want to talk about
correct names in a second thing on top
of this if you're running it yourself
you'll also have a backing internal
database most of the time at Etsy D if
you're running it internally you can use
external data stores of the
configuration as well and if you're
running on a cloud chances are you'll
also have a cloud configuration manager
which is what actually communicates
really the underlying cloud provider
itself so if we're running custom
containers on top of a cloud provider
you'll probably have one of these taking
it one step further and looking at
worker nodes this is just some form of
computer like when we're talking about
these nodes here these could be virtual
machines these could be physical
machines these could be raspberry PI's
sitting in the corner of your office or
something to set up by the way this runs
your workloads and the container run
timer lives here this is what's actually
kicking everything off now something to
peek behind the scenes a little bit
further everything we've talked about
previously is also containers so it's
Turtles the whole way down but on the
worker node is where you normally think
of the click of that container runtime I
live in it
in reality you have to call kubernetes
services the couplet which is what
actually talks to the container runtime
to start and stop your containers and to
proxy which is what sets up the
networking layer and networking is where
things get a little bit more
interesting we'll have a chat about that
services a little bit later on you also
have your container runtime of choice by
default this will be docker but you can
switch it out if you prefer something
slightly different so we have our master
nodes and our worker notes our master
nodes is where a configuration store
this is the brains of the cluster our
worker nodes is where our workloads
running this is where everything happens
so kubernetes is it is is if it has I
mean we're talking about two degree
abstractions we're talking about being
able to deploy applications without
worrying about underlying operating
systems but at the same time we've just
spent in the past five minutes talking
about virtual machines well in reality
it's it's a little bit of a strange
space and this is very much my opinion
on my take on the story from the is
perspective we still have master and
worker node management we still need to
look after virtual machines but in terms
of deploying our applications we don't
care about those virtual machines we
don't care how many's there we don't
care about the underlying network we
just give it a deployment and have it
run and we're abstracted from those
Hardware abstract for those workloads so
to a degree kubernetes kind of signs in
the middle where there's some components
that are very VM forests some components
that are very application focused and it
really depends on the future side of it
that you sit a lot of organisations may
choose to have their traditional ops
team look after the infrastructure
components while letting their
developers provision workloads to
kubernetes of the self this tour degree
gives you the separation of duties
between your infrastructure and your app
deployment you can break that down
further with networking and security and
so on and so forth
but it's just a little bit of an
interesting concept to think about it
there's also another option I don't want
to manage masters managing masters just
means I have a bunch of extra bands
laying around can't someone take care of
it for me well it just so happens as
soon as you move to majority of cloud
providers they offer a managed
kubernetes service a couple of examples
as a community service the Google
container engine have to call it out
these provide the management plane has a
so you're no longer looking after those
virtual machines in a turn it's actually
moving the master work master node
management from being looking after VMs
to simple click box configurations and
this is incredibly powerful not only
does it save you cost in most instances
because we're not actually paying for
the master nodes themselves but it also
means they're managed at scale by
someone else
to a degree the less control you have
the less responsibility you have which
is nice in the world so digging into the
nuts and bolts of kubernetes
this is probably where you'll begin to
hear a couple of terms of specular if
you haven't used kubernetes before that
sound vastly different and we're gonna
run through them bit by bit with a
couple of demos as we go sort of them a
pod when we look at kubernetes we don't
tend to talk about explicit containers
we talk about holds pods are our lowest
level deployable unit this is what we
spin up a pod can be made up of one or
more containers and in my mind I really
just wanted to say a pod can be made up
of one container because we're only
doing 0 to 100 here in reality for the
majority of scenarios you will only have
a single container in the pot there
won't be a large number of them and a
pod to a degree is a single instance it
is 2 degree
taking the critical to cookie-cutter
making a stamp and leaving it there most
people may think they want pods that
they don't necessarily want pods by
themselves so a pod has a container
inside of it a little bit of semantics
here your pod technically doesn't run on
the containers running inside the pod
and they will be allocated to a node but
the pod itself will never actually run
us so there's nothing special or smart
about a pod it's more like a logical
boundary as we said before we can have
multiple containers inside of this pilot
and they can share a networked space so
they can talk backwards and forwards
between each other and a whole lot of
other components that you can set out on
where you would use this sort of
scenario
if you wanted logging or monitoring or
have you put enough buzzwords in this
presentation so far if you want to do a
service match using sto and take a
completely different approach to
networking that's when you'd use
multiple containers inside of part
because of HOD is the smallest unit we
can deploy it's also the items that we
scale so if all of a sudden we deploy
two containers to a pod it means we
could never scale those two containers
independently the life cycle of all
containers within a pod is stuck
together it's kind of like gluing
containers together and saying these are
eight unit and that's it so for 0 to 100
stick with this this is nice this is
easy it's simple and it makes a lot of
sense and this is why if you read
through a lot of online documentation
people will actually mix up and I could
do it from time to time container
important because there's really that
one-to-one relationship from the
majority of scenarios sort of let's spin
up a single pot I'm gonna jump back to
my demo virtual machining and the first
thing I'm going to show you is well I
want to get started with kubernetes and
I'm really really lazy like really lazy
so I don't want to set up a cluster I
don't want too many virtual machines I
don't want to do anything fancy we'll
just so happens docker desktop actually
contains kubernetes as well which is
rather nice if you open up the docker
desktop there's a kubernetes tab down
the bottom that allows you to click a
button enable kubernetes and you're good
to go this is great for local
development this means you can run it
locally to your heart's content there
are alternatives to this as well things
like the mini cube entirely contained
kubernetes environments that you can use
for development and testing purposes so
we're going to be working with this
today the first thing I'm going to do
and we're going to do this through
docker for through the docker desktop
interface first we're going to do it
through the command line a little bit
later on I'm going to choose what
context I want to be looking at and
vastly simplifying context this is the
cluster that we're pointed to so in this
case I
set my context to docker desktop now
what does that mean our context contains
a pointer and some authentication
details to a cluster or more importantly
to that API server we were talking about
before that sits on the master in order
to administer and work with a kubernetes
cluster we tend to use tube control now
there are graphical interfaces for
kubernetes you can install a really nice
portal and have a great graphical
experience
please start when you're starting start
with the command line it makes it a lot
easier to understand what's happening
it's a little bit quicker and all the
commands you learn and learn as you go
will actually be used diagnosing later
on when you've got an issue being able
to pull logs this way it's a lot easier
there's a whole lot of niceties that you
can add at the end of the day the
command line is the place to start so
like we had docker which was the CLI
that talked to the dock adamian
we have cube controller which in turn
talks to our kubernetes api server so
this allows us to talk backwards and
forwards so I'm gonna do a coop control
and let's do a - - help love - - help
this is the first place to start so this
is everything we can do with kubernetes
oh sorry with coop controller the first
thing we'll look at is a get also
because I want to make sure the demo I
tested before this is already spawned
out so if we do it with cout control get
and we can specify the object that we'd
like to get and we've only really
explored one so far Halas so if I say
coop control get pods awesome
still hasn't my last demo hasn't that's
alright so our cube control get pods
allows us to see what pods are running
within an environment now what if we
actually want to deploy a pocket well
originally I was going to do it through
the command line but please don't do
that it's been deprecated don't create
things directly through the command line
templates are the way to go to because
templates are a little bit easier to
read so what does a pod template look
like won't as we saw before a pod was
that outer boundary so
and this is the Yammer format that will
be seeing everything in today for a pod
but we have an API version this is an
internal internal indicator kuba
needless to say what API which we'll be
using things we've got our climate which
is a pod and then we've got some
metadata and the metadata will become a
little bit quite important a little bit
later on but for the moment we're just
using it to name this pod and inside
this we can list containers I've got one
container here we could have many if we
want this is the smallest deployable
unit in kubernetes so how do we actually
deploy this and get this run run well we
come back here I'm gonna change into my
demo environment and another quick tip
for those looking at getting started
really quickly there are two ways to
apply configuration you can do it file
by file or just apply the entire
directory in one go and be done with it
now applying the entire directory is
fantastic when you know the order of
things though you've only got one file
in there if you go to deploy one file
and you have hundreds in there and you
apply the entire directory it gets very
messy very quick so to start off with
we're just going to apply a single file
so we're gonna do a cube control apply -
earth
so we're saying we want to apply a file
here we want to apply the template that
we just saw and in to this we're going
to pass our young your file so this is
you're pointing to the file we had a
look at kicking this off we'll say hey
the pod is created and ready to go so if
we now do a cube control get your hops
we can see that at the top there our
demo - pod is running and happy and
healthy the only problem is we've said
hey run a pod and that's it what if that
hard crashes and burns irrecoverable
what if the node it's on
shuts down and stops the two-degree
disappears it stops it stops working
upon by itself doesn't give you any form
of kubernetes resiliency to integrate so
the container by itself depending on its
restart policy may kick itself back off
at the crashes but it won't by default
move it across nodes we have
think it'll level above a pod - actually
to actually get any form of resiliency
in the infrastructure so the opposite of
a cube control apply is acute control
delete and once again we can just pass
in a file and it will use the names in
the file itself to remove those
components so as I can do a cube control
applied to create the deployment sorry
to create the template a cube control
delete will remove all enemy elements
within the template these two commands
will become your best friends in terms
of working with kubernetes templates and
spinning things I'll come down so that
pods been deleted it will get off and
leave in a couple of seconds awesome
we're talking about a single pilot and
please don't use single naked pods
they're not designed to be used that way
it's a pod is great if you just need
something to run but it doesn't give you
any layers of protection what most
people will tend to refuse is one level
up from a pod which is a replica set and
a replica set is a way of defining a
template for a pod and give it a count
of how many we want what this looks like
in reality is this now there's an
interesting concept here the pods don't
live inside the replica set the replica
set is responsible for spinning up those
pods but they don't explicitly leave it
inside they're just they're just pods at
the end of the day what the replica set
does have though is its template and
that template allows us to define what
is deployed in this case if we said we
want to replicas the replica set will
spin up those pods on our behalf for us
this is powerful because if we now say
hey I want three replicas we have three
pods running on if I then change that
back down to two we now have two pods
running likewise if while running two
pods a a node goes down we lose a pod
somehow it just disappears into the
ether or we explicitly kill the bottle
the replica sets gonna realize hang on a
second I've only got one
hot running evening I've just received
an event in so I'm actually gonna spin
up a brand new pod in its place so a
replica set is basically guaranteeing
that we're always running two copies of
this template now what most people
actually want when they start using
kubernetes is basically this I want one
replica of this pod and guarantee that I
will always have one copy of this pod
running so if we were to delete this pod
if we were to take down a node if we
were to somehow destroy the pod the
replica set would re spin up that hot
Forks sort of them let's actually have a
bit of a dive into it so just as before
we're gonna have a look at the template
behind it and then apply it and have a
bit of a play lately so a replica set it
is a little bit longer than just a
straight part here we have our here we
have our replica set at the top we have
a selector and we'll get back to that in
a second and a template and the template
should look exactly the same to a degree
as our pod definition this is absolutely
fantastic because it means we can reuse
some of those components and under the
hood this is just a pod template the
important thing to note here is our
match labels and I've given these all
different names on purpose because
there's no explicit relationship between
a replica set and a pod we have to
define one so this is where we're saying
that hey any pod we spin on give it this
application name and make sure it
matches this label when it promised so
let's spin this up and have a good
awesome
so the replicas created if we now do a
cube CTL get pods we should see that our
demo three has two replicas spun up and
ready to go were all up and running if
we were to kill one of those pots for
example so if I was to now do a cube CTL
delete pod and then pass in this name
terminate it to get rid of it so there's
now only one code running what we'll
find is it's already started spinning up
a brand new container in its place
because it's figured out that hey this
container is stopped we can also see if
we set - wide that these are running
across multiple different no sorry this
is on my local machine so they're all
running on the same node in reality if
we had a multiple Network node cluster
these would be spread across those now
one thing to keep in mind we can change
the replica count we can't change the
template technically you can but bad
things happen
replica sets are great if we want to run
on one thing and that's it but what if
we want to continuously update it
increment over the top of it well that's
when we begin to use deployments before
I do that a quick another hundred 100
plus wide there are more than just
replica setters there are jobs staple
sets Damon says that all have their own
intrinsics on how they run on the
cluster level above a replica set it is
a deployment and a deployment is
responsible for creating multiple
replicas CETIS as updates come in
the nice thing about this is we can
actually roll back our changes of nice
graphic so we have a deployment you'll
notice the deployments is to the side of
the replica set it's all staying the
same familiar a deployment contained the
template and template is then deployed
into the replica set in turn then
deploys the individual pods if we change
our container template to v2 for example
the deployment spins up a brand new
replica set and starts provisioning pods
within there automatically if this is
successful
then it'll reduce the number of replicas
that are on our original replica set
until it hits zero and until we have the
correct number of replicas on our new
target replica set we can also fail back
using this method of actually undoing
that change failing back to that old
replica set so if we jumped in now and
have a look at what a deployment looks
like and this is going to be the
surprise of the day if it looks exactly
the same the only thing that really
changes here is that it's a kind
deployment instead of a kind' replica
set it that's it a deployment is really
just an abstract constructor on top of
this to allow ease of deployment so
let's jump back in and do a cube control
delete this is the fun of doing
everything live on stage cool clean out
our old one
let's change across to our demo for
awesome so same command again you see
the CTO apply - yep and instead of
giving it a file I'm just gonna do dot
dot means hey just do everything in this
follow and it's created the deployment
so if we do a cube CTL get in
deployments we should see that there's a
deployment there ready to go you'll
notice that our ready is zero of two
this is saying what's available if we do
a cube CTL get replica set it we can see
that there is this is why you should
always clean up things give me 30
seconds
let's clean everything up make sure it's
disappeared and recreate everything from
scratch cook so we now should have our
deployment sitting minute we should now
have our replica set one replica set it
because I didn't clean up doing my pre
demo testing and we've got two replicas
in there if we now do a cube control get
hot
we should Cesar there's two pods they're
running and ready to go if we were to
change on deployment so for example
change this this is demo number four and
this is just outputting to the log in
the background as a sample template
workload so if we change this template
kick this off again and apply the same
thing apply the configure over the top
don't apply the template over the top we
see it's being configured now if we have
a look at our deployments you'll see
that there are two ready only one of
them is up to date and tour available
and it's because I wasn't quick enough
to do this if we do a cute control get
pots we should actually see that our old
two pods are terminated and our new two
pods are running and ready to go if we
then have a look at our replica sets we
can see there's now two so it created a
new replica set once it was able to
provision and spin up pods with that
replica set it deep provisioned the old
ones allowing us to failover now we can
also issue an undo command here to fail
back but in the interest of time I'm
gonna skip on a little bit it's got a
little bit more to cover this is great
we can run workloads in a reliable way
we can define our deployments which
allows us to update those workloads to
our hearts content how do we actually
talk to these workloads though if I'm
running on my local computer then that's
not too bad I can use my local IP but if
we've got a cluster of a couple of
different nodes comes a little bit more
difficult especially if I want port 80
to be
used between multiple feelings and we'll
get to that in a moment it comes
incredibly complex well we can actually
define services and a service is very
simply sitting on top of all of this and
points directly to the pods themselves
and it's two degrees of locator saying
hey I want to talk to this service which
in turn talks to these pots we also have
the ability to change how we publish our
services we can say that it's cluster IP
which by default is internal only so we
can't talk to this service but we can
also say no port if we want to make it
available on every node as a thought
itself or in cloud scenarios we can use
load balancer and load balancer
basically means spin up a load balancer
on my behalf and set it up taking
everything one step further as we do I'm
gonna switch context now so I'm gonna do
a cube CTO and switch to a IKS cluster
rather than my local cluster because I
want something on the public internet
I'm gonna do context cool and we can see
all the different contexts that we've
got there in this case we've got the
NDC's demo that we can change to so I
can now do a use context to switch and
this is basically switching from one
cluster to another in DC demo and now
we've switched across so instead of
pointing towards my local kubernetes
cluster I'm now pointing to a cluster up
in Azure just so we can have some
publicly public Ivies attached to this
thing so for a service we add another
component to our Yammer
so this isn't an extension to the
deployment it's a new resource that
we're adding side-by-side so down the
bottom here we've got the deployment
very similar to the last edit instead of
giving it a dummy workload this time I'm
giving it n genetics the same thing we
used previously the only difference here
is we now have a service of the top now
we have a selector again and a selector
is what holes should this service look
to walls so you'll notice that my pods
have similar labels of demo 5 service
app and that's the selector that it
actually uses to point to those services
without a selector you'll service 1.2
anything you need a selected actually
say what you wanted to point towards now
in all these templates and they'll be
available in github afterwards I've
given everything different names
the main reason because when you first
read through one of these templates
everything's given the same name and you
have no idea what is what so I like to
give them explicit names to spell it out
of it sort of deploying this we're gonna
jump back in to our last folder actually
we're gonna do to make sure we cleaned
up perfect
I'm gonna jump back I'm going to going
to demo 5 and let's do a cute CTL apply
everything in the folder and you'll now
notice that there's two lines that have
come out we've deployed both our
deployment which contains our replica
set which contains our pods as well as
our service now this is actually going
to take a couple of minutes to spit up
so we're gonna jump on and come back to
it one thing to know when we do a cube
CTL services you'll actually see here
that it's been given in an internal
address in the cluster we also have an
external IP pending what this is
actually doing in the background is
spinning up an agile load balancer on
our behalf to talk to this cluster and
this could be perfectly honest is the
easiest way to get inbound traffic into
an a KS cluster so running on top of
agile if you're running this yourself
you may not have access to these sort of
load balancers so there are other
options we won't dive too deep into it
today but running in the cloud makes
things easier a little bit of a surprise
surprise
so that will kick off and do its thing
boom we've got an external I panic if we
were to hit this external IP we should
hopefully get the welcome to nginx done
so successfully to find a deployment to
find our pods set a service and attach
to an external load balancer to this all
in maybe 10 lines of Yammer now exposing
services is great and especially handy
if you want multiple containers to talk
to each other internally but sometimes
you need a little bit more control or
more importantly you want more control
without taking on responsibilities this
is where ingress comes into play
say for example you need multiple
containers speaking on the one IP on the
one URL but with different paths you can
use ingress ingress rules to define
paths that should be routed to
containers and the classic example here
is I have two services surface a and
service be listening on port 80 I want
to create an ingress rule and say /foo
should go to service a slash bar should
go to service billing
now under the hood this uses an ingress
controller which we skipped over a
couple seconds ago I'm just using nginx
here but feel free to use whatever
ingress controller you like whether it
be traffic or there's a whole lotta
different options out there
this is a little bit of good fun now
template looks very similar to what we
saw previously where we have two
services the biggest difference here is
these services don't have a type of load
balancer specified yes so we're not
actually showing we're not actually
saying these should be external these
are only internal to the cluster so we
have two services one for service B and
one for service a we have our
deployments exactly as we saw them in
the previous step these are literally
just copied and pasted with just
services fee and services changed in the
names and we're also using a custom of
container
pulled from an azure container registry
instead of how to point for the second
one the only new thing we have down the
bottom here is our ingress rules and is
basically defined for /foo point this to
service a four slash bar pointless to
service Bailey that's it
that's the high level constructs we need
to get this up and running on it so if
I'm now to cube CTL delete delete
everything off then jump into my last
demo perfect and do a cube CTL applied
to it and apply that template you notice
we have a lot of things deployed now
more than more than the two resources we
had before the biggest thing we actually
get now is those two services created as
well as this ingress rule now this is
where we're going to jump a little bit
behind the curtains in order to talk to
these ingress rules we needed to have
deployed an ingress controller look at
what ingress control you want to work
with and follow the guidance there's
normally a one step helmet chart or
similar to use totally out of scope for
today but in order to see what I hear
that ingress controller is listening on
we can do a cube control get services
and instead of getting services
that are available here I'm actually
gonna switch it to another namespace and
a little bit out out of the scope of
today but it basically allows us to
logically segregate different workloads
so I'm gonna do def - name space ingress
- basic which is and you'll notice that
we have our ingress controller sitting
inside of here which has an external IP
and that external IP when we talk to it
with slash through we get service a
slash bar we get service so ingress
controllers are incredibly powerful
now I actually marked these sliders 100
+ start off with just services and
deployments keep it simple
alright let's switch back very quickly
and I'm gonna do a rapid-fire
run-through of things you might be
interested in it but don't necessarily
don't necessarily know the names of so
these are all beyond the scope of
today's session and the reason I'm doing
them quickfire is just so you're aware
of them we can auto scale we can scale
our pods horizontally in and out based
on metrics we can scale our nodes our
underlying compute in and out as well
depending on the provider meaning you
can add completely elastic workloads
this does not come by default you need
to put it in your configuration
kubernetes doesn't instantly mean auto
scaling it just gives you the ability to
set up auto scaling lower units we
haven't talked anything about stateful
workloads this ability to attach storage
in such a way that you can run database
service stateful workloads whatever you
want namespaces give us logical
isolation on top of the cluster so we
can have one area for team one one area
for team two one area for dev one area
of the test affinity and anti affinity
we can control where can where pods are
placed in terms of keeping them close to
each other or as far away as possible we
have tanks and toleration and I'm going
really quickly so tenkan toleration this
allows us to define what pods should be
run on what nodes with hard limits great
example here I only want this pod to run
on a node that has a GPU attached that
has some form of extra compute or some
specialty resource quotas we can also
begin to limit how much memory I'll
contain it containers and pods can
actually use Azure kubernetes service
run it in the cloud that's all I'm gonna
say give this a go it's really easy to
provision and for time reasons we're
gonna skip the demo of spinning it up
the biggest thing to remember is you
have no master nodes you don't pay for
that compute the control plane is free
which all of a sudden it saves you the
cost of three virtual machines the
powered kubernetes though is the fact
that you could run it on premium in a
remote environment but somewhere
isolated that doesn't have access to a
master control plan with just a set of
the ends to a degree run everywhere it's
that container portability so to a
degree the portability doesn't actually
come from the fact that it's kubernetes
comes from the fact that it's containers
awesome last but not least because we're
right on the money I mean you've used
some tips and tricks what do I recommend
you do to get started today keep it
simple please keep you configurations
keep your templates as simple as
possible don't go to Phobos only put in
only putting the components that are
required you don't want to have a ten
thousand line template that you have to
wade through to try and figure out
what's happening group where appropriate
we kind of touched on it we can have
multiple violence so if we had a complex
architecture we can break it down across
multiple files to make it easier to read
and consume in saying that if I had two
deployments two services and an ingress
rule I may choose to just put it in the
one file because it makes it makes it
easier to read as one file this is
completely up to you as to what you go
just yet please don't have that
directory with 10,000 files ordering of
those
is incredibly difficult single pot a
replica set no one likes a naked pod
give it some form some form of
protection look after it
replica set with replicas one is what
everyone's looking for by default this
is this is what everyone thinks
kubernetes does for a pod by default you
need a replica set even medic go for
deployment take advantage of deployments
something we didn't touch on avoid hosts
down networking we can bind two ports on
a host we combine two entire IPS on the
nodes themselves try and avoid this
prefer services or ingress controllers
where applicable and news lately we only
really looked at a name label today but
you can give it additional information
you can give it and component part of is
a fantastic one one being able to say
give me all pods that are part of
application a and get a list of all of
those back is really really handy more
of a personal one
don't use latest please don't use latest
we won't get into it too much today and
I know if working all these rules by
doing this presentation latest is bad
latest changes latest changes not in
term not only in terms of what's sitting
on the container registry we all expect
latest to always be up-to-date having
latest changes the way kubernetes pools
container images and it ranges it in a
drastic way if we explicitly specify a
version it will use a paste copy of it
when it's spinning up new containers
meaning is incredibly fast to start if
we specify latest latest has this
intrinsically the ability took to pull
always so every time we start up a
container it's talking out to the
container registry checking if it's the
latest version pulling a copy of the
latest version spinning up and doing its
thinning if we explicitly have version
numbers it's a lot better right sized
home nodes small clusters are fantastic
for dev but please don't have tiny
clusters in prod and cube controller
learn the CLI and apply everything in
the folder this is fun command just make
sure there's only one thing in the
folder when you do that
perfect and as we do today start
stateless stateless is the easiest way
to get started we don't need to worry
about storage we don't need to worry
about using files because there's things
on a network it can talk to any virtual
machine you want so we've literally gone
zero to a hundred with a mass load of
acceleration towards the second half
there but I hope you enjoyed hope you
got a good understanding most
importantly remember kubernetes is your
scheduler you need that container run
time under the hood to actually run the
containers pods are our smallest
deployables replica sets is how we'll
deploy multiple plots and our
deployments is our top level what we
like to use services allow us to target
particular pods and ingress gives us
greater control over traffic into the
cluster I'm going to leave it there
thank you so much and because we've gone
over time come see me afterwards the
questions
[Applause]